Trascrizione: Maria Pericleous
Revisore: Chiara Polesinanti
Buonasera a tutti.
Cosa ci fa un filosofo
in un ambiente
completamente tecnologico?
Me lo chiedo spesso,
soprattutto quando mi serve
con urgenza una stampa
e la stampante si blocca,
oppure quando devo parlare
in una riunione online
e sono l’unica in tutto l’ufficio
alla quale non funziona la connessione.
Insomma sembra sempre
che la tecnologia mi sia avversa.
Il problema è che siamo abituati
a dividere le competenze,
cioè a pensare che solo facendo
un particolare percorso di studi
ci permetta di aprirsi
a lavorare in un certo ambiente.
Così quando io dopo la laurea in Filosofia
ho avuto la fortuna di entrare
nel mondo dell’Information Technology
mi sono sentita veramente felice.
Però avevo una paura folle,
non sapevo niente di tecnologia.
E la prima volta che sono stata affiancata
a uno dei guru dell'azienda
che con sua buona volontà
cercava di trasferirmi
i fondamenti dell’informatica,
tutte le sigle IT, ICT, IRP,
mi sembravano degli enigmi da sciogliere.
Poi mi è venuto in mente
uno dei momenti più belli
del mio percorso filosofico.
Una lezione di filosofia della scienza
sulla rivoluzione copernicana,
la rivoluzione che per eccellenza
viene definita come il momento di rottura
da un tempo a un altro,
da un pensiero a un altro
e che tutti noi usiamo quotidianamente
come espressione comune.
Cosa ti combina Copernico
per avvalorare il suo eliocentrismo?
Chiama in causa Ermete Trismegisto.
Ermete Trismegisto
è una figura mitologica
che gli alchimisti
avevano preso come simbolo
tanto quasi da farlo
diventare una figura reale.
Ecco, Copernico, nel suo elogio al sole,
chiama in causa una citazione,
cioè per avvalorare il suo eliocentrismo
chiama in causa una citazione
di Ermete Trismegisto.
Quindi si fa un po’ un autogol,
prendendo a valore della sua teoria
prettamente scientifica
contro i dogmi,
una componente di pensiero e filosofica
completamente all’opposto.
Questo di fatto ci fa pensare una cosa:
che l’uomo non è mai solo né tecnologico
né razionale né scientifico,
ma è meravigliosamente complesso,
che è frutto del suo tempo
e di tutte le influenze
che nel tempo si trovano.
E quindi questa meravigliosa complessità
è forse la cosa più preziosa,
cioè la sfida da proteggere,
che noi dobbiamo avere tutti i giorni.
È veramente la rivoluzione
che l’innovazione deve portare.
In vent’anni di lavoro
nell’Information Technology
questa è stata un po’ la mia passione,
e la passione che condivido
con i colleghi,
e che ci ha permesso di scardinare un po’
gli schemi della comunicazione tecnologica
e che ci ha forse anche dato l’opportunità
di accompagnare in alcune attività
la crescita dell’azienda in cui lavoro
che è stata grandissima.
Proprio partendo qui da Empoli
è diventata una realtà internazionale
e però ha mantenuto
le sue radici qui sul territorio,
quindi è una sfida veramente grande.
Insieme ai colleghi, dicevo,
abbiamo trasformato parole strane
come “cloud”, “blockchain”,
o “data science” in racconti
di persone e racconti di imprenditori
racconti di colleghi.
Perché se c’è qualcuno che sa trasferire
la vera rivoluzione della tecnologia
e quanto impatto ha
sulla vita nella sua interezza
sono proprio le persone.
Quando fanno, quando raccontano
il vero valore di quello che adottano
sulla loro vita concreta.
In fondo, come diceva Protagora,
che è un filosofo sofista
del IV secolo a.C.,
davvero l’uomo è misura di tutte le cose.
E diciamo che questa è proprio
una visione umanistica ante litteram,
ma che è veramente contemporanea,
perché oggi il digitale
è in funzione di tutti noi,
della nostra vita
e della nostra esistenza.
E poi se ci pensiamo “digitale”
deriva da digitum, cioè da dito,
e quindi da un’unità di misura
veramente umana.
E se ci rivolgiamo indietro
nell’ultimo anno e mezzo,
vediamo quanto il digitale sia stata
la misura della nostra vita,
quando durante la pandemia
tutti gli schemi si sono rotti,
delle nostre abitudini,
tutto l’ordine
che avevamo nella nostra vita
si sia scardinato.
Eravamo abituati ad avere
una vita privata,
una vita lavorativa,
e con la pandemia
l’una é entrata in ingerenza nell’altra,
e così abbiamo dovuto imparare nuovamente
ad avere delle abitudini.
Heidegger sosteneva
che l’uomo è veramente tale
solo quando viene gettato
in un luogo di cui non conosce niente
e a vivere una vita
di cui non conosce le leggi.
Ecco, per noi la pandemia
è stata veramente il luogo sconosciuto.
E oltre ad imparare nomi
di tutti i familiari dei colleghi
oppure degli animali domestici
di tutti i colleghi,
veramente ci siamo dovuti rendere conto
che tutte le caselle
in cui noi individuiamo le varie parti,
le varie aree della nostra vita
non sono mai state così separate.
E quindi questa meravigliosa
complessità dell’uomo
in cui l’una area entra
nell’area dell’altra
andava di nuovo di nuovo protetta,
di nuovo conservata,
e il digitale è stato lo strumento
che non solo è stato lo specchio
di questa estrema complessità
e di questo disordine,
ma è stato l’unico strumento
per garantire la complessità dell’uomo.
Ho lavorato in un ambiente
che ha organizzato dei corsi
per aiutarci a gestire
la nuova metodologia di lavoro,
che ci ha permesso di imparare a capire
che lo smart working
non era solo lavorare da casa,
ma che era proprio uno schema
completamente diverso.
E mentre imparavamo questo
però avevamo capito
che dovevamo definire
un nuovo stile di comunicazione,
e quindi abbiamo dato vita ad un percorso
che è iniziato proprio
nella prima fase del lockdown
e che ci ha permesso di collaborare
in maniera completamente diversa
con tutti i colleghi
che c’erano in tutt’Italia.
E diverso è stato mettere al centro
le passioni e la nostra creatività
come base di tutto il lavoro,
perché se ci mettiamo in gioco
completamente,
in ogni momento della nostra vita,
le passioni sono davvero
la linfa vitale che va nutrita
e soprattutto se si lavora
in un ambiente tecnologico.
Quindi proteggere la complessità
e la varietà dell’uomo
ci porta anche a pensare un altro aspetto,
che bisogna proteggere anche la differenza
che ciascun uomo porta avanti.
Ma Draghi poche settimane fa
ci ha parlato di questo, della differenza,
parlando del piano del PNRR.
Lo ha definito come un’occasione storica
per far sì che le nostre imprese
possano avere una chance di ripresa.
Ma lo ha anche definito
un’opportunità incredibile
per abbattere qualsiasi differenza,
quella di reddito, quella di genere,
ma anche quella di generazione,
perché solo gli ambienti
che accolgono la differenza,
in tutti i suoi aspetti,
sono ambienti veramente ricchi
in ogni ambito della nostra vita.
Come donna, chiaramente la differenza
che mi sta più a cuore,
o forse che sento di più,
è quella della differenza di genere.
Soprattutto perché noi dobbiamo lottare,
tante volte di più degli uomini,
per ottenere le pari opportunità,
e soprattutto perché lavorando
in un ambiente come quello
dell’Information Technology
che è prettamente maschile,
è ancora più complesso.
Se si pensa solo che le donne
nel nostro ambiente
si attestano circa al 25 o 30 per cento,
si può capire come la parità di genere
nel nostro ambito di lavoro
sia ancora difficile da raggiungere.
Ecco...
Diciamo che le cose stanno cambiando,
non solo perché io lavoro
con un gruppo di donne
veramente determinate, tenaci,
forti, a volte anche troppo --
ma diciamo che a volte, quando si deve
far sentire la propria voce, si alza,
e questo è una condizione naturale
per determinarsi di più --
ma anche da un’analisi che ho fatto
con osservazione più ampia.
Da tre anni mi occupo di organizzare
anche, sempre in azienda,
tutte quelle attività
che sostengono le donne,
e le giovani ragazze,
e che le vogliono incitare
a percorrere dei percorsi formativi
e delle carriere STEM.
Ho collaborato con La Sapienza
per organizzare Women Courage,
un evento internazionale,
che La Sapienza ha organizzato a Roma.
Insieme abbiamo fatto dei seminari,
e abbiamo fatto un hackathon
per le ragazze provenienti
da tutto il mondo.
È stato bellissimo,
perché il tema vincitore
di questo hackathon
era l’Intelligenza Artificiale,
è stato vinto da un team
di ragazze Italo-Turche.
Non vi dico la difficoltà
di spedire i premi in Turchia.
Insomma, va bene, tutto una cosa
molto complicata.
E poi ho collaborato
anche con l’associazione
Informatici Senza Frontiere
e un’altra iniziativa molto carina,
molto interessante,
che avevamo organizzato nella scuola
del territorio, la scuola Vanghetti,
e con la dirigente e con i docenti.
Era un percorso formativo
sempre in ottica di carriere STEM
per le donne,
di istruzione di qualità,
però dedicato alle bambine,
perché alla diversità
bisogna educare fin da piccoli
e forse le scuole medie
sono ancora troppo tardi.
Diciamo che però
la bella notizia dell’anno
è arrivata per noi
durante la nostra convention,
perché da sei anni organizziamo
un hackathon a tema,
che è aperto a tutti i ragazzi
delle scuole e delle università
in tutta Italia.
E se nella prima edizione
c’era una sparuta donna,
quest’anno invece la presenza femminile
era pari al 50 per cento.
È quindi stata una grande soddisfazione,
perché abbiamo ampliato,
abbiamo accolto la diversità,
abbiamo dato vita ad un qualcosa
di bello che ci ha arricchito.
Per concludere,
io volevo ricordare una frase,
quella del “conosci te stesso”.
“Conosci te stesso” era la frase
che era scritta sul frontone
del tempio di Apollo a Delfi
che ho visitato,
in un viaggio meraviglioso.
La frase non c’è più.
Però Socrate l’aveva ripresa
per stimolare i giovani
ad avere coscienza di sé,
di tutto quello che c’è
di umano e disumano,
per conoscere i propri limiti,
per conoscere anche le potenzialità,
cioè dove si può arrivare.
E quindi l’incitamento che lascio è:
ripartiamo dal conoscere noi stessi
per mettere in atto
la rivoluzione dell’innovazione.
Grazie.
(Applausi)